[Music]
hello
hello is that you shan yes speaking
ishan
i'm just calling you from samuel 365 you
put a question in
oh yes yes uh
yeah it's actually no it's actually
samuel
oh okay i was just watching your video
nice so you've got you're looking to buy
hmo i think you had an issue regarding
the license situation so
what can i do for my friend oh no
no i'm just going to start the the
printing rental rate yeah so i just want
to know how to
how to get a hmo license like what do i
need to change
um into the house uh to get the human
license
okay so have you got a property in mind
or are you just
asking generally because you're in just
speaking to landlords
because i'm just at the moment
yeah recently um
sorry i'm just nervous oh don't worry
it's fine this is what this is this is
what i do all the time my friend
yes uh yeah i just started the
course yeah want to know like the basic
stuff
and then start yeah good
good well firstly congratulations for
joining samuel 365.
um mad respect and literally anytime you
need anything you can just
book a call jump on a court it won't
necessarily be me it might be tony or
one of one of our one of our
uh one of our mentors but so feel free
to be that annoying person that books
a million calls it's all good we got you
back we're here for you that's what this
is about
um so in terms of rent to rent have you
um
have you got a patch in mind for where
you're gonna start speaking to landlords
or are you literally just brand spanking
new and and looking
i mean where sort of where are you at in
your journey yeah
i'm looking for like in uh
yeah and there are other places like
aldershot
swindon like three or four places yeah
cool
yeah great okay
so listen in oxford if you're turning
any property into a hmo
like even if it's a three bed hmo you're
gonna need a license
so my suggestion esham would be
if you're looking to do rent to rent
rent to hmo
would be to find landlords who are
already running their houses as hmos
they've already got a license they're
already doing it as a hmo but the reason
they're losing and the reason they need
you
is because they're trying to manage
themselves
the house is a bit shabby poor
management
poor furnishings poorly advertised
poorly marketed
basically they don't understand how to
run a hmo business
so i would be going on places like spare
room dakota uk
finding properties in oxford oxford's
brilliant by the way
i've got um actually i've got a student
i don't know if you saw her name stella
samuel
and she's got a few uh rent to hms in
oxford she's making four thousand pound
a month she's got a few properties
killing it in oxford right now oh i
think i saw her video on youtube
yeah so oxford's great but so swindon
and so is the other areas you spoke
about but what
what what you should do is you should
find
landlords that have got hmos already so
they've already furnished it
they've already got a license they've
already got planning that they might
need to get they've already got it all
set up they've done all the hard work
but where they failed is they don't know
how to
find tenants because they're marketing
it all wrong they're probably living
maybe they're living landlords and
they've just moved out and they're just
all messed up and
they're worried about the pandemic
they're worried about and you're going
to say well listen how about this how
about
you've got five rooms available you've
only got two people in there
so how about i'll give you a guaranteed
rent of x and you're gonna try and get
that small as possible
and then say and then and then um you've
got it guaranteed peace of mind no
hassle and then i'll keep any profit
that i make on it and
and listen um make sure you of course
you put a break clause in a three-month
break laws so that if after three months
it's not working
for you you can walk away make sure you
put down as little money as possible
but you're just going to tart it up
you're going to remarket it you're going
to manage it properly
and then you're going to make cash flow
off the property but i think that would
be the best
that'll be the best advice that i'd give
you is starting out looking to do
rent events in those areas
want to get going like like if i have
like a certain kind of contract
to show to the landlord so i want to i
need a help to
make a contract um like
and so i can i can convince to the
landlord so
it's all about the contract and then
finally maybe yeah
listen i don't think a contract is going
to convince anyone of anything
what's going to convince the landlord is
by you offering them a good service and
being confident and reputable
the contract isn't isn't going to do
that um
the kind of contract you're going to
need is you're going to need a
management
um you're going to you're going to need
a rent to rent management agreement
um but but but that isn't gonna that
isn't gonna win them over and
of course you know if you get someone
that's interested and you're like oh my
goodness i need a contract you know
give us a shout and we'll give you the
details and sort you out on that on that
front
but that is not gonna that is not gonna
win them over what's gonna win them over
is you isham
yes yes
yeah thank you thank you you're so
welcome listen give me a call anytime
book a call
and um go kick some ass and if you need
anything let us know and how are you
getting on with the training on the
samuel 365 have you done like the uh
have you done the dfe and stuff
the deal finding extravaganza the online
courses that are on the samuel 365
yes i'm in the um
like f4 good listen number four
nice well if you get stuck give us a
shout okay
okay all right all the best you're very
welcome cheerio
this is what we do man mentor people
calls but you know what it's worth it
because the hard work that i put into
doing all this
it's worth it because if it wasn't for
this we wouldn't have winners on a
wednesday
so if you're interested in receiving
mentoring calls from myself from the
team
going through the training you pay one
pound have a seven day trial
and then it's 95 pound a month no
cancellation charges
no penalties nothing crazy like that and
i'll leave a link in the description so
thanks for watching peace out
[Music]
you